did your parents sort of uh tell you hey
james
or jimmy jimmy you're really good excuse
me did they call you
um no okay no not so much
uh i wouldn't say like the best thing
that i got from my parents was complete
apathy towards whether or not i should
be an actor like they just didn't really
didn't care like it's up to you you know
do what you want they weren't really
against it they weren't really that
forward either so you didn't have to
really
you didn't try did you try to prove to
them that you were good that you always
were always trying to like
look at me i'm great were you that guy
were you that kid that was just like i
want
everyone to know i'm great because look
i think i did i think i have
many times in my life like i want i want
to be great so people think and that's
obviously not the way to be
yeah i definitely was like that there
was a time when i thought that if i
couldn't be the greatest actor in the
world there was no point in trying
at all and and then then you you come to
realize that
that there's no real competition in art
you know that all artists we're all
trying to just
uh get honest with ourselves and express
what we find
so like um like i couldn't
i you would never want to do
uh rebel without a cause like the remake
if you get the call we're remaking rebel
without a cause you want the lead you
know you would never say yes to that
because you cannot
touch james dean and you can't you no
success will be
in in redoing that but i don't know if
james dean would make the greatest spike
frankly exactly so i i'm only trying to
be the best
me